qui veut comptait saumon de génération f
bonsoir professeur merci d'être avec
nous on l'a vu en certains sénateurs qui
accuse des députés d'une certaine
frilosité sur cette loi climat vont vous
partager ce sentiment
c'est une grande mascarade cette loi en
gros c'est l'illustration du en même
temps de monsieur maquereau en même
temps on ne fait rien et en même temps
on en parle mais ya rien dans cette loi
qui soit de nature à permettre
d'atteindre les objectifs de la france
en matière de réduction de ses émissions
de gaz à effet de serre les sujets qui
viennent d'être évoqués par exemple sur
l'avion on le voit 0 effets réels
surtout avec eux les mensonges qui
permettent de dire que quand on est dans
correspondance on peut quand même
prendre l'avion sur la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments
une modification des règles de calcul
des émissions et des consommations qui
font que la recul encore par rapport à
l'existant
non on est devant une grande
mystification mais c'est la preuve que
en matière d'environnement
monsieur macro est vraiment très très
très très vieux monde
il est d'une certaine manière l'otage et
ça a été dit dans votre reportage juste
avant il est l'otage en réalité des
lobbys qui ne veulent absolument pas
qu'on puisse toucher à leur profit et
donc toute mesure qui se ferait au
bénéfice de l'humanité mais au détriment
du profit et rejeter systématiquement
pourtant yves contassot il ya certaines
dispositions qui font grincer des dents
alors vais pas pleurer sur les
collectionneurs de vieilles voitures ont
sans doute mais enfin il ya sept
disposition qui dit que les
collectionneurs de vieilles voitures
n'auront plus le droit d'aller dans les
villes en certains s'en sont mve
on est un petit peu dans le punitif
c'est ce qu'on reproche parfois
d'ailleurs au vert c'est tout simplement
d'interdire son sommation voie d'entrée
dans la liberté des gens la première des
libertés
la première des libertés c'est de
pouvoir vivre or là nous le savons
aujourd'hui avec la pollution
atmosphérique c'est quarante mille morts
par an en france avec la destruction de
la biodiversité ses victimes en toute
une partie du monde végétal et animal
qui disparaît et si l'avenir de
l'humanité ni plus ni moins qui est mise
en cause
alors évidemment ceux qui sont dans
l'égoïsme de court terme disent tant pis
pour nos enfants nos petits enfants se
débrouillent durement et puis si
l'humanité disparaît dans quelques
milliers d'années probablement pas pas
d'ici la fin du siècle évidemment et
bien moi je serai plus là pour le voir
donc cet égoïsme est absolument abjecte
pas d'autre mot et je crois qu'il faut
au contraire que l'on fasse comprendre
que c'est notre avenir collectif qui est
en jeu et non pas du tout une punition
on peut très bien vivre avec un
chauffage dans sa maison à 20 ou 21
degrés plutôt que 22 ou 23 degrés comme
c'est la moyenne aujourd'hui en l'oubli
mais on est dans un gâchis absolu
on n'est pas obligé d'avoir des
appareils qui tombent en panne
systématiquement au bout de deux ou
trois ans dès qu' à la fin de la
garantie
on n'est pas obligé d'avoir des voitures
qui surconsomment alors qu'il ya eu des
milliards donnés aux constructeurs pour
arriver à fabriquer des voitures avec
moins une consommation inférieure à 2
litres aux cent donc on voit bien que
les solutions sont connues il n'ya pas
la volonté politique
alors on parle aussi de l'interdiction
des voitures de critères 3 dans les
grandes agglomérations
il faut aussi se mettre à la place des
gens promouvait le diesel
avant et maintenant on leur dit
débrouille débrouillez vous avec vos
voitures autres on n'a pas forcément les
moyens de s'acheter une nouvelle voiture
et donc et vous avez raison vous avez
raison il y a eu pendant des années et
des années et y compris à gauche
des tas de gens je me souviens de madame
ségolène royal faisant vraiment
panégyrique du diesel alors qu'on le
savait déjà que c'était une catastrophe
et qu'il faudrait l'interdire un jour ou
l'autre
bien oui à gauche comme à droite il ya
des gens qui n'ont pas voulu regarder la
réalité en face et on le sait depuis
très longtemps quand on reporte les
décisions elles sont plus compliquées
alors aujourd'hui il faut accompagner
les gens je suis d'accord surtout parce
que ce sont souvent les plus pauvres qui
ont le plus de mal à changer leur
véhicule et il faut sans doute interdire
les très gros véhicules très polluants
au bénéfice d'une aide à ceux qui sont
absolument contraints d'utiliser leur
véhicule
quelques compositions clairement de la
convention citoyenne n'ont pas été
retenus metric selon vous était
indispensable mais il y en a tellement
que c'est compliqué vous savez sur les
149 la plupart près de 80% ont été d'une
certaine manière soit détournée réécrite
avec en réalité un objectif contraire à
ce qui était proposé quelques unes sont
mises en oeuvre mais avec une
restriction dans la mise en oeuvre la
question de l'aviation qui est une des
pires je dirais en matière d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et d'une
certaine manière symbolique
on le sait aujourd'hui il faudra
interdire les vols
lorsqu'il y a moyen de déplacement en
train qui est en gros de l'ordre de 4
heures l'as aurait du sens mais à à 2h30
et avec cette histoire de correspondance
ça n'a aucun impact à huit derniers
éléments ont c'est la priorité des
priorités la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments
et là encore pas grand chose avec des
changements sans arrêt tous les ans sur
les règles fiscales sur les aides qui
sont apportées une année on considère
qu'on peut changer les
après on peut plus et c'est tout ça
n'est pas sérieux ouais vous satisfaire
en revanche de la proposition de baisse
un plat de la tva sur les billets
trinquent d'ailleurs le gouvernement et
les députés n'avaient pas voulu mais
c'est tout à fait indispensable si
aujourd'hui on veut redonner toute sa
place aux déplacements en train il faut
effectivement arriver à ce qu'on ait une
terrasse très réduite
mais j'ajoute que dans le même temps il
faudrait impérativement re développer le
fret ferroviaire
rien n'est fait dans ce domaine rien
n'est fait et je rappelle que le premier
transport routier français c'est la sncf
à travers ses filiales
donc là encore double discours merci
contassot monde génération est d'avoir
été avec nous sur nous sur rt france